the aquamarine waters of the
mediterranean surrounded by craggy
cliffs keep luring tourists to these
coves
however vacationers aren't the reason
this small italian island has made
headlines in recent years
in 2013 368 migrants and refugees died
when an overcrowded boat capsized near
lampedusa it was one of the worst
shipwrecks in modern european history
francesco barrata's father was fishing
with a friend when he heard cries for
help he rescued a dozen people and
became a national hero
the people who think all migrants are
criminals don't understand what it means
to suffer for something
and forget that the westerners have
exploited the same africa they came from
after people protested the days when
asylum seekers arrived and roamed the
narrow streets are long gone
now their presence is invisible to most
prompting one woman to accuse our crew
of spreading misinformation
there is a problem when the sea is very
calm like today we see at least 1 500
people arriving each week they are
immediately transferred to cilicy or
somewhere else we don't see them on the
island
yet the migrant welcome center is
overflowing
the uptick in arrivals coincides with
the collapse of prime minister mario
draghi's coalition government this month
he announced his resignation twice
far-right and populist parties torpedoed
draghi's government and are expected to
prevail in snap elections on september
25th
the maguiri siblings come from one of
the oldest families on lampadusa they
make a living selling produce out of a
truck in the city center
we should vote for the far right and
give them an opportunity to run the
country before we say they are not good
currently migrants are coming here every
day without any rules
barrata hopes italians won't allow far
right and populist candidates to
scapegoat migrants
almost a decade later his father has
remained in contact with some of the
people he rescued and he says the
sadness in their eyes remains natasha
ghanim al jazeera lampadusa italy